John Stuart how much do we love him I'll
go first a lot a lot a lot the multi
Emmy winning comedian returns to
political satire with this new movie
it's called irresistible the former
Daily Show host wrote produced and
directed this comedy it's about a
small-town mayoral race there's a word
mayoral race
Steve Carell and Rose Byrne played rival
Democratic and Republican strategists
think about that for a second who bring
big money and national attention to the
Wisconsin town election the Democrat
Party can't win they're getting
desperate they don't know us they don't
want to know us and they know that's we
your DC elite I know actually I'm from
here
I know you're from Wisconsin mm-hmm yeah
well no Jurlique and I'm from dearly oh
wow so this campaign has been a bit of a
homecoming
it really is Brooke thank you no no no
that's a lie that's a lie no if you're
lying it's so well done John Stuart hey
hey John Stuart joins us from his home
somewhere in New Jersey John Stuart it's
so smart it's so funny it's so
thoughtful those two by the way have how
shall we say a sexual history which also
adds to it raunchy campaign finance
reform film you gotta really go on I
pictured you sitting on your computer
wherever you do this stuff just cracking
up as you're writing this what were you
thinking political satire go ahead I'm
sorry where I write I'm up here with the
rabbit and the guinea pig in the ride so
I really try not to make any noise
because they get attacked me at any
moment I we don't know what's gonna go
on up here what are they here in the
Attic you know you kind of look like you
are in the Attic where did the idea come
from
I was looking yeah you know just the
system and just how large it had grown
that sort of media industrial complex
and how much
money was in it and how much sort of
just kind of propagates itself and it's
like a game of musical chairs there's no
real accountability when the music stops
nobody ever loses the chair they win the
election they don't win the election
they just keep making money there's more
money in and more influence and I always
thought what would it be if somebody
used that system's energy against it
like a judo move yeah I saw you know
they spend 50 million dollars on
off-year rational elections and it's
it's just gotten it's gotten worse I
know and you know what John you take a
mat both parties in this movie you wrote
it with Steve Carell in mine what were
you thinking what were you thinking that
Steve would be the perfect person to
play this role because he's great in
this he works very cheaply a little bit
of my catering and I wanted to save some
of that money obviously for the catering
she's so good I mean first of all a
lovely human being but so funny and
listen this character is not the most
likeable individual in the world but
when you have somebody like Steve doing
it you it allows you to spend more time
with that character without trying to
punch in the head John I don't know I'll
just say this I want to talk about the
news of day because I certainly miss
your voice during this particular time I
always find myself thinking what would
you think what would be your takes I'm
serious about this because I find a lot
of my white friends are calling me
saying what to do how to do or a lot of
white people calling you your white
friends calling you and saying what do
we do with this time because we're at a
very crucial time it's very painful I
think people are scared I think people
are afraid and really don't know what to
do they're doing deep dives and
self-reflections
you getting a lot of calls from people
are you talking about this with your
white friends what is the conversation
yes no question I think that a lot of it
is how do we move past to offensiveness
nobody likes to be called out on things
that you know
there's a couple of things going on I
think the first step is probably
educating that you know that gap that
existed and you know black people have
been put in the position in this country
to negotiate their humanity with the
powers that be and at each turn it's
been denied to them and there's been so
much pain and anguish and blood spill
and yet we haven't recognized that while
they were fighting desperately for
equality or the country and white people
in the country we're building equity
yeah and if you don't close the equity
gap you can't talk about the Equality
gap yeah you were making such a good
point and I'm also finding a lot of
people doing a deep dive and
self-reflection have you done that for
yourself when you look at things that
you've said or done in the past or
things you wish you could change like
what I mean we had you know when it
started out television as you know Gail
is a is a white male and it was
certainly when I started in it
and the inertia of the system you can
have people in the system that aren't
necessarily racist but participate
passively in a system that over the
years I mean here's here's a great
example the majority of the people that
would be hired to produce television
shows come from internships you know
because you meet them when they're young
and if somebody impresses you if an
opening happens well who gets the
internships yeah generally it's more
affluent white kids whose parents able
to afford to let them take three months
and go to New York so the tributary
that's feeding the larger system is also
rife with that inertia and it's not
enough to just
say okay then we'll start a program
where we don't allow for internships
people have caught like you have to
change the entire framing around how
these feeder systems grow they shouldn't
it feels like it shouldn't any longer be
about concessions like affirmative
action like you okay okay I get it
400 years house five points on your
college application sound well I do
think this John cuz you know how this
works we have to go but I do think at
this moment in time America is looking
in the mirror and doesn't always like
what it see what it sees and now maybe
just maybe there will be some changes
we're in the middle of a political
campaign have you decided who you're
going to vote for yet then we got to go
and thank you
the movies called irresistible it opens
in theaters today and it's available at
home on demand